today i want to take a few minutes to
tell you about a really cool project
partnering with the david pakman show
called pumapay
and you can find out everything that's
going on with them on their website
to which i've provided a link down below
pumapay is a decentralized finance
payment protocol
which facilitates peer-to-peer
transactions through billing models that
are
really interesting so what we're talking
about here
is payment technology powered by
blockchain
and crypto pumapay's mission is to bring
the flexibility of payment cards
to blockchain through a variety of
billing methodologies that they've
developed such as blockchain-based
auto top-up billing recurring payments
and many others so basically puma pay
makes crypto payments accessible to
everyone really really interesting
pumapay is probably best known for
what's called their
pull payment protocol this technology
makes it easy to do
automated crypto billing it has
completely changed crypto payments by
allowing transactions to be completed
in a poll direction rather than a push
pumapay's solution
was developed from the ground up mostly
for merchants in high risk industries
because it's businesses like these
that are most in need of such a solution
industries that deal
with things like chargebacks and auto
payments and pumapay now has a growing
network of integrated
high-risk merchants that are global
leaders in their respective
industries which brings us to puma pay
3.0
puma pay is powered by the native token
pma
that's been around for a few years and
at the current stage in the development
protocol
it is puma pay version 3.0 or v 3.0
and this version introduces some
significant improvements to the platform
so much so that v 3.0 is going to be 100
times faster
and yet 50 times cheaper than the
previous puma pay and as a result
pumapay says that their system is going
to see some extreme optimization in
performance lower gas
fees support for multiple currencies and
total decentralization of the protocol
which is huge here's some of the major
changes
in v 3.0 the migration of the protocol
from ethereum to the binance smart chain
establishing a bi-directional bridge
between both networks so users can
transfer pma tokens from ethereum
to the binance smart smart chain and
back
support for more tokens and a mechanism
to swap
tokens automatically upon payment this
will let users pay
with whatever token they want merchants
can settle with the token
they want and that includes stable coins
and this will help merchants avoid the
crypto volatility risk we've talked
about for so long
introducing liquidity pools and
automatic swaps
full decentralization of the back end
and the introduction of
executors and full compatibility with
metamask
and other wallets to facilitate payment
and settlement in any currency
pumapay is now introducing liquidity
pools to the ecosystem and the goal of
doing this
is encourage people to deposit liquidity
to puma pays pools because the amount of
liquidity puma pay can accumulate
will be a key measure of their success
to encourage people to deposit they've
created a unique reward system as well
as potential for generating earnings
with pumapay
which should be unlike anything
currently available in the defy
space and the details are as follows the
first liquidity pool
pairs pma with bnb and that started on
may 6th of this year on the pancake swap
platform the liquidity goal is 2 million
dollars by july 1st
and the total reward will be 750 million
pma the rewards will be distributed
according to each liquidity provider's
relative share of the pool by the date
of allocation
a reward multiplier will be awarded to
those who deposit early and so i'm
showing the chart here
which breaks down all of the reward
stages now one thing to note
is they will have a special reward set
up for liquidity providers
where early depositors can receive the
reward multipliers
pumapay says that their protocol will be
the most advanced crypto payment
solution on the binance smart chain the
bsc
and in fact pumapay says they'll be the
first ever defy
platform solution to facilitate
recurring crypto billing
on bsc and these liquidity pools are
going to be an integral part of that
system
each transaction is expected to generate
up to two swaps
and this is because merchants and users
will be able to settle and pay in any
currency
with pma being the mediator and sole
means of value transfer over the
protocol and liquidity providers
will earn a fee pumapay has been a
really interesting project to watch over
the past few years
i'm going to continue paying attention
to what's going on with the company and
the technology
i invite you to learn more about what
they have going on especially puma pv
3.0
and the liquidity pools that we've
talked about you can find
all of the information on their website
i've put a link right underneath this
video
and of course this is not a financial
endorsement suggestion or advice for
anybody it's a
discussion of the project everybody
should do
full and extensive due diligence before
making
any decision that will impact your
finances